mind your decisions i'm presh talwalkar
you have a rectangle with dimensions of
two and one and you have a second
rectangle of the same dimensions
now rotate the second rectangle and
place it on top of the first rectangle
in such a way that their opposite
corners overlap
the question is what is the area of the
overlapping region between the two
rectangles
i thank robin for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
i will present one way to solve this
problem
consider the following right triangle
and suppose the other leg has a length
equal to x
since the entire side of the rectangle
has a length equal to 2 the remaining
length on this rectangle will be equal
to 2 minus x
by symmetry the other rectangle will
have exactly the same lengths the
portion that's not overlapping will be
equal to x and the portion that is
overlapping will have a length equal to
two minus x
we can then consider just this right
triangle by the gogo theorem x squared
plus one squared is equal to the
quantity two minus x squared we can then
expand the binomial
the x squared terms will then cancel out
and we then have a linear equation
we can routinely solve this equation for
x and we get that x is equal to 3 over
4.
let's substitute that into our diagram
we now want to consider the area of the
overlapping region
let's also consider the area of this
right triangle which is congruent to the
other right triangle
we thus have the area of this
overlapping region plus the area of two
of these triangles will be equal to the
area of the original rectangle
the rectangle has an area equal to two
times one which is equal to two
two of these triangles will have an area
equal to three over four multiplied by
one which is equal to three over four
we thus can solve for the area of the
overlapping region and it will be equal
to two minus three over four which is
equal to five over four and that's our
answer
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you